Guten morgen tim.
Tim ich habe besseres zu tun.
Logbuch politik nummer dreihundertundsiebzig und vierzig und wir blicken auf das datum und es sagt uns sechsundzwanzigster mai zwanzig zwanzig der sommer naht das corona geht alles wird gut.
Ja genau.
Da wir oft nicht optimistisch ausklingen kann zumindest schon mal optimistisch einsteigen.
Ich bin ich bin sehr gespannt wie sich das jetzt entwickelt ja bei den letzten sendung ein bisschen von den korona maßnahmen kritik und so gesprochen und da fällt mir gerade ein,
es gibt da es geht glaube ich auf einigen seit einigen tagen schon auf twitter die runde dieses,
alfons blumen ja ein wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche vierundachtzig jahre alter mann der in pirna auf so einer.
Corona kritischen also corona maßnahmen kritik demo steht ja und diesen ausschnitt oder diesen beitrag zu schauen kann ich wirklich nur allen empfehlen das ist sehr beeindruckend
der mann ist also über achtzig jahre alt ist seit einigen monaten jetzt von seiner,
ähnlich alten frau getrennt die in einem in einer pflegeunterstützung ist und riecht also quasi in dem interview in tränen aus.
Weil die seelische belastungen natürlich eine irrsinnige ist und die sorge und die angst die diesen menschen umtreibt und der ja wirklich dann auch mit einem.
Legitimen sinnvollen anliegen da steht wenn er sagt hier diese maßnahmen sind eine seelische folter für mich und dann.
Kommt so ein schwabler von links.
Kommt so so ein typischer osthus ja,
und pöbelt ihn dann da an dass er die kontrolle über sein leben verloren hat weil er weil er den öffentlich-rechtlichen traut ja also ein ein absoluter unsinn und dieser mensch der wirklich mein dieser tool hat im leben keine sorge mehr weil er
also keine reale sorge weil er,
die gar nicht erfassen kann und dann hast du halt die den iphones blumen der dann eben sagt so 'ne nähe moment man muss schon vernünftig bleiben wäre es mit einer panne mir zu tun das ist wirklich eine beeindruckende beeindruckender moment der.
Sehr klar zeigt dass in in welcher lage sich die gesellschaft nämlich gerade befindet mit,
machen wir uns nix vor einer einer herausforderung auf die halt auch die antwort noch nicht bekannt ist und wo sich hoffentlich wirklich meine hoffnung in der jetzigen phase des tanzes mit dem tiger sich.
Herausstellen wird dass einige maßnahmen zu krass waren zu weit gegangen sind das hoffe ich wirklich dass das das
kommt das ist das wo was wir jetzt alle hoffen müssen dass sich herausstellt dass bestimmte maßnahmen in ihrer drastic fehlgeleitet waren weil wenn das nicht rauskommt heißt das wir müssen zurück zu diesem
zustand der der den wenigsten leuten wirklich angenehm war also es ist ein zu erwarten das ergebnis dass man jetzt feststellt was weiß ich diese maßnahme.
Ich nehme jetzt spezifisch kein beispiel aber sagen wir eine kita schließung oder was weiß ich der verzicht auf flugverkehr oder was auch immer war zu viel ja eine andere weniger.
Krasse maßnahme hält das pandemien geschehen in einem erträglichen rahmen wir haben also als menschheit gelernt.
Und das ist dann gut.
Und das ist aber jetzt auch deswegen wollte ich das gerade nochmal benennen halt diese diese kritische phase in der wir jetzt sind wo nämlich die afd natürlich jetzt schon die messer wetzt und sagt so super jetzt
kommt jetzt können wir uns darauf einrichten dass quasi fehlentscheidungen bekannt werden oder.
Entscheidungen bekannt werden die rückblickend betrachtet.
Fehlerhaft waren oder nicht optimal waren und dann können wir irgendwie groß theater machen das ist die phase in der wir jetzt sind in der in der öffentlichen diskussion scheint mir so ein bisschen so.
Ja also bin mir nicht so sicher ob du mit deinen beiden beispielen da ein treffer landen wirst aber,
selbstverständlich wird das so sein ne also selbstverständlich werden wir feststellen dass bestimmte maßnahmen vielleicht so nicht erforderlich gewesen sind und einschätzung falsch waren weil man halt einfach nicht wusste so und
das ist ja klar ne man versucht halt schnell zu reagieren alle versuchen das richtige zu tun aber es ist ein bisschen wie beim programmieren fängst auch nicht an programm zu schreiben und startest und das läuft das auch perfekt sondern es hat alles irgendwie box und braucht optimierung da stellt man halt erst fest wenn man es auch mal ausprobiert hat.
Dass ein beispiel was ich immerhin vorträgen nehme microsoft windows xp hat dreizehn jahre lang updates bekommen und war auch dann nicht fertig sondern halt of life.
Schlagartig.
Na ja das ist ist kein totschlagargument sondern es zeigt einfach dass.
Dass wir also wie code eben ein leben das objekt ist ne ich hoffe jetzt nur nicht dass wir dreizehn jahre corona pandemien haben ne das wäre schlecht.
Vorbei wenn wir die sache weiterhin beide von dem bill gates lösen lassen dann müssen wir auf jeden fall worauf wir uns einlassen.
Naja naja.
Aber ja es gibt ja jetzt auch zum jetzigen zeitpunkt schon kein mangel an unvertretbar wortmeldungen da fangen wir dann mal gleich mit unserem lieblingsfressstand herrn maaßen an.
Der hat nämlich auch wieder sendung titel ausgegraben.
Der hat also wir wissen ja,
dass herr maaßen muss man tatsächlich sagen wir wissen ja dass er ein besonderen narren gefressen hat an zum beispiel netzpolitik org aber auch am chaos computer club ja es war.
Es gab da die ein oder andere unheimliche situation die auch gezeigt hat dass der genau weiß wer wir sind und sich halt mit uns beschäftigt will ich jetzt auch gar nicht sagen dass,
ist auch richtig so dass er das tut weil er schließlich,
ja wir seine politischen feinde sind insofern ist das nicht überraschend dass er sich mit der kritik und mit dem politischen gegenposition auseinandersetzt ist aber natürlich beim beim inlandsgeheimdienst chef immer so ein bisschen gruselig ne.
Vor allem wenn man da sind sachen vorgefallen da schlaufe nicht so pralinen zum geburtstag sag ich nur das ist.
Hast du bekommen oder was.
Nein ich nicht.
Sondern werden.
Sag ich jetzt nicht aber jemand also es wird echt gruseliger scheiß ne,
so ich weiß wo dein haus wohnt wo ich weiß wann du geboren bist ne das ist halt wirklich so.
Gruselig naja okay lassen wir es also der setzt sich mit uns auseinander hört offenbar auch logbuch netzpolitik weil.
Ich glaube tatsächlich der der credit für dieses zitat gebührt dir glaube ich tim du hattest ja gesagt voll verlängern schon in einer sendung das grundgesetz verstößt gegen die geheimdienste.
Beziehungsweise in dem fall das gesetz da ging's um weiß nicht mehr genau worum es ging aber nicht ums grundgesetz.
Es ging glaube ich um die also es kann ja nur um untersucht.
Ja wahrscheinlich doch genau das ist war das bild gesehen.
Geheimdienste.
Oder um das gesetze also ist das gesetz verstößt gegen die geheimdienste und ja genau das hat hans-georg maaßen jetzt auch eingesehen und und twitterte.
Am zwanzigsten mai.
Im interesse der sicherheit deutschlands und seiner alliierten wäre es besser das grundgesetz der rechts praxis anzupassen als dieses weltfremder urteil umzusetzen das war sein kommentar und ich ja es ist.
Also dass der dass der sich traut das auszusprechen ja das ist wirklich also ich kann nur sagen mir gefriert das blut in den adern bei diesem mann ja ein ein offenkundiges,
rechter verschwörungstheoretiker der lange zeit des bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz geleitet hat.
Und der bis vor kurzem auch noch so von der gesamten regierung bank gedeckt und geschützt wurde
bis der öffentliche druck so stark war ob seiner illustren äußerungen dass er einfach nicht mehr haltbar war es hat aber auch lange gedauert.
Unglaublich also das ist wirklich gruselig ich hab's ja damals gesagt den der wird dann zum posterboy der rechten und ja herzlichen glückwunsch.
Das ist er jetzt.
Zu den zum thema grundrechte und das kniff glaube ich auch an an diesen aspekt
weltfremd den er da ja benennt gab es bei uns in den kommentaren auch eine ja eine diskussion aufklärung darstellung die ich mal zitieren möchte weil ich denke dass wir das in der letzten.
Sendung wahrscheinlich nicht.
So gut herausgearbeitet haben wie das in diesen kommentaren nochmal betont wurde und da kommentierte unmacht die grundrechte der bundesrepublik deutschland gelten auch außerhalb der grenze der bundesrepublik deutschland ja,
offenbar möchte ich hier das bundesverfassungsgericht als welt verfassungsgericht gelten und das ist ein eindruck der sich ja durchaus.
Widerspiegelt auch in dem titel grundrechts realismus und diese argumentation und ich denke das ist ein sehr guter punkt weil.
In der gesamten diskussion um das urteil immer wieder der falsche eindruck entstanden ist dass das der leitsatz des urteils wäre und da korrigiert und er erklärt gut sweati.
Die grundrechte beschränken den deutschen staat in seiner handlungsfreiheit.
Mehr aber auch nicht weniger dass diese beschränkungen des staates in seiner handlungsfreiheit nun nicht an landesgrenzen aufhört sondern sich auch.
Staatliches handeln im ausland grundsätzlich einschränkende auswirkt.
Beißt sich absolut nicht mit der präambel des grundgesetzes die nämlich,
das deutsche volk bindet also und so steht es auch in dem in dem urteil drin dass die grundrechte,
oder die die grundrechte schränken das handeln des deutschen staates ein und dieses handeln des deutschen staates hört eben nicht an den grenzen auf und das ist denke ich nochmal eine wichtige erklärung zur,
argumentation dieses urteils und auch zu bedeutung dieses urteils dass eben ein staat.
Nicht seine sämtlichen grundrechte und verfassungsrechtlichen beschränkungen am ende der grenzen.
Oder an den grenzen abwerfen darf weil dann wenn das der fall wäre dann könnten deutsche behörden oder so da ja auch im ausland foltern weil ist ja schließlich nicht in deutschland.
Oder im weltraum.
Im weltraum weltraum folter joy teuer aber aber legal.
Was schreien sie denn haben sie denn haben sie denn unsere weltraumthemen nicht studiert.
Ähm.
Und dann hatten wir noch einen kommentar von wort der das urteil ein bisschen kritisch betrachtet und den fand ich als als meinung oder als einordnung dessen was jetzt hier geschehen ist auch.
Mal zitieren wert.
Ja ich lese das mal vor das urteil legalisiert full take der rohdaten durch den n,
und dies wird für alle zukunft auch andere behörden zugestanden werden die vollkommen verständliche grundrechtsbindung deutscher amtsträger in deutschland abzufeiern bedeutet dass man erst geringe ansprüche an einem sogenannten rechtsstaat stellt.
Immerhin dürfen für weitere jahre straftaten begangen werden ohne dass die täter dafür jemals belangt werden es handelt sich ja um
uneinsichtigen intensivtäter der bnd ist ja bereits bei seiner gründung eine kriminelle vereinigung von schwerverbrechern gewesen dass beispielsweise ein bundespolizist an der grenze sein ausländischen kollegen auf der anderen seite der grenze,
weil diese angeblich keinen grundrechtsschutz genieße zu keinem zeitpunkt erschießen oder mit steinen bewerfen durfte ist wohl immer schon eine selbstverständlichkeit gewesen,
die absurden behauptungen der täter klammern virtuelles ausland wird theorie funktionsträgern theorie und deren hintermännern sind ja offensichtlich schutzbehauptung um den dringend notwendigen strafrechtlichen verfolgung zu entgehen
es ist daher mehr als dringend eine reform der dienstaufsichtsbeschwerde strafrechts notwendig,
die justiz insbesondere generalbundesanwalt schafft ist hier teil des problems das hier das b v g straftaten weiterhin billigt ist sehr bezeichnend.
Ich denke das ist harte argumentation aber also harte worte aber durchaus eine perspektive die man hier durchaus drauf haben kann.
Und wahrscheinlich leer leider die die in zehn jahren klüger klingt als sagen wir unsere einen etappensiege fürs erste zu feiern.
Immerhin etappensiege.
Immerhin.
Dann gibt es noch ein kommentar von den ich quasi als kleine hausaufgabe für die für unsere zuhörerinnen,
kurz weitergeben würde und zwar sagt könnt ihr mal für nicht experten erläutern was diese automatisierte überwachung an einem internetknoten punkt in der praxis bedeutet soweit man das von außen beurteilen kann ich kann mir das als laie leider nicht vorstellen was mit mitlesen genau gemeint ist
könnt ihr das mal an vier beispiele nennen was weiß ich mail unverschlüsselte mails seite aufrufen und so weiter
meine bitte wäre wir haben das hier schon öfter erklärt und leider weil wir hier ja
auch die nachrichten der woche behandeln wollen ist passt das jetzt nicht in diese sendung also wenn ihr da helfen könntet mit einer empfehlung in welcher sendung wir das mal gut gemacht haben.
Fände ich das ganz nett,
also ich bin mir sicher dass ich das öfter mal gemacht habe den wir auch aus sicher dass frank das mal in der sendung hier erklärt haben wird werden ja auch klaus landesgeld da also da empfehlungen,
glaube ich wird sich freuen und danken.
Ja dreihundertsiebenundvierzig sendung wir verlieren den überblick.
Ja ich wir warten auch nur noch hier auf den moment dass wir anfangen können die alten sendungen zu recyceln und die euch so merkt keine sau.
Merkt ihr nie das.
Schon wieder vorratsdatenspeicherung och die season die setze ich aus.
Aber schalten sie wieder ein zum season finale.
Ja sie ist im finale das.
Da gibt es einen neuen twist.
Okay.
Neue gesetze gibt.
Neue gesetze bei das war ja auch wieder ein also ich habe wirklich den eindruck dass diese bundesregierung noch mehr als die gleiche bundesregierung zuvor.
Dieses dieses hat ja also ich habe das ja auch bei jens spahn sieht man das wieder und immer wieder dass er,
seine ideen kurz mal an die diskutieren lässt guckt wie der testballon so abgefeiert wird in der öffentlichkeit und dann erst seine gesetzesvorschläge rausgibt das ist,
finde ich ich weiß noch nicht mal ob ich's.
Unbedingt anders machen würde weil es natürlich sinnvoll ist seine ideen zur zum regieren des landes oder zur legislativen regulierung des landes.
Vorher mal an der öffentlichen meinung zu spiegeln ja das ist schon mal ganz gut ja aber wie das hier passiert führt halt zu einer echt starken verwirrung und macht,
dient auch glaube ich sehr absichtlich der zerstreuung des
widerstandes deckt sich auch ein bisschen mit der äußerung von horst seehofer der ja so sinngemäß gesagt hat gesetze müssen kompliziert geschrieben sein damit keiner merkt,
so sinngemäß hat er sicher geäußert und,
haben wir hier mit dem it-sicherheitsgesetz zwei null auch gehabt weil ich glaube es ist sicherlich,
über ein jahr her dass frank und ich dieses diesen referentenentwurf da mal diskutiert hatten zum it-sicherheitsgesetz.
Indem es nämlich noch diese ganzen ideen gab zur darknet illegalisieren ja da ging es also darum wer.
Die formulierung war sinngemäß wer infrastrukturen oder dienste betreibt die der dem dem,
begehen von straftaten dienen ist dafür dann irgendwie haftbar,
ja und da ist natürlich dann genau die frage die sich immer wieder stellt bei so sachen wie provider privileg ne also ist ein hoster dafür verantwortlich dass du alle dateien auf diesem server hast ist ein v p n dafür verantwortlich dass du damit,
vielleicht auch mal ziehst und so weiter wo wir wirklich an einem grund fest an einem der grundfesten prinzipien
des internets und seiner regulierung rütteln danach dieser ganze teil scheint jetzt raus zu sein.
Das ist schon mal positiv beim it-sicherheitsgesetz zwei null das jetzt gerade wieder aufgestiegen ist.
Nicht da drin ist eine meldepflichten also meldepflichten für sicherheitslücken ja die meldepflichten für sicherheitsvorschiften gibt es ja in den weiten teilen der so,
benannten kritischen infrastrukturen so benannt ist hier,
eine neologismus von mir.
Der aber genau sagt wird nicht diese die werden nicht so genannt sondern die werden so benannt ja also es es gibt ja durchaus lücken was jetzt kritische infrastruktur ist und was nicht
zum beispiel teile von luftraumüberwachung und gesundheitssystem sind keine kritische infrastrukturen dafür.
Was weiß ich so gut wie jede stadtwerk eine interessante.
Interessant wie sich da eben diese kritischen infrastrukturen herauskristallisieren die er eben per verwirrst das dann ist das eine verordnung.
Also die werden auf jeden fall vom.
Bmw in der richtung irgendwo quasi per anordnung benannt und das ist nicht unbedingt in dem gesetz geregelt also es ist nicht gesetzlich geregelt dass du kritische infrastruktur bist sondern per anordnung.
Die aber natürlich irgendwie groben prinzipien folgt naja also die idee wäre jetzt gewesen eine melde pflicht für schwachstellen,
zu implementieren die also sagt okay du bist jetzt verbunden du bist wenn du wissen über eine bestimmte schwachstelle hast die andere betrifft,
verpflichtet die zu melden und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe hätte diese eben,
primär natürlich für die staatlichen organe gegolten.
Das hatte seehofer auch mal versprochen da hatten wir uns auch schon irgendwie gedanken drüber gemacht naja moment melden heißt ja nicht dass ihr dann damit auch ordentlich umgeht dieser ganze teil ist auch raus was jetzt in dem aktuellen
it-sicherheitsgesetz aber besonders hervorgehoben wird ist die aktive suche.
Die durch das bsi stattfinden soll also hier ist die rede von betrieb von honey pots um eben das angriffs geschehen erforschen zu können also hanni pots sind.
Angriffsziel mit oder vermeintliche angriffsziel mit schwachstellen die dem zweck dienen zu gucken aha wie agieren den angreifer.
Wenn ich den mal hier ein ungefähr also ein quasi eine kontrollierte eine von mir kontrollierte umgebung hinstelle.
Und schaue was sie damit machen wenn sie die von mir dort absichtlich angebrachten schwachstellen ausnutzen.
Ja um dann eben zu gucken aha woher kommen angriffe welche fähigkeiten haben die angreifer welche tools benutzen die angreifer und so weiter sind.
Auch wohl soll das bsi das recht bekommen aktive scans zu machen also mal.
Den den internet-star der bundesrepublik deutschland abscannen und gucken aha was werden denn hier so für services angeboten und so und.
Dabei dann nicht nur den ja sagen wir mal also ein port käme ja gleich dem anklopfen also um das jetzt mal einfach zu sagen gibt eine adresse im internet dann klopfst du halt mal an.
Sag mal welche dienste werden denn hier angeboten und diese,
wenn wenn spätestens ab dem moment wo du zwei dienste anbietest sagen wir mal ein webservices,
und ein also eine webseite und ein mailserver hast du
mindestens zwei ports offen ja in dem fall einmal den port für eingehende e-mails könnte dann zum beispiel pott fünfundzwanzig sein
und den port für,
traffic also für die webseite das könnte dann pott achtzig sein könnte aber natürlich sein dass du dann außerdem noch die webseite als p s anbietest dann hast du in der regel noch vier drei auf ne also jeder dienst den du anbietest benötigt,
einen port und ein pot scan wäre eben an diesem ports anzuklopfen und mal zu gucken,
antwortest du mir wenn ich wenn ich dir hier eine anfrage hin sende,
dann kann man sich darüber gedanken machen ok stellst du nur eine verbindung her oder sprichst du dann auch mal mit dem dienst und dann geht's nämlich immer weiter bis zu dem punkt,
sagst du zum beispiel auch mal ach hier.
Hier ist ja eine ich erkenne das ist ja ein admin interface für eine next cloud ich versuche mich da mal mit admin admin anzumelden.
Ja da wäre dann irgendwo verläuft der verläuft dann die grenze zwischen einem ja nur mal anklopfen,
und einem mal gucken ob ein standard schlüssel passt zu einem aktiven scan auf fehlt konfiguration und schwachstellen
ja du kannst auch zum beispiel so etwas machen wie was weiß ich gucken ach hier das ist ein wordpress machen wir mal ein fingerprint welche version das ist oder auch das bestimmte schwachstellen aufweist ja also das wäre ja alles dinge.
Die möglich sind.
Und die im wenn man jetzt von einem größeren unternehmensnetzwerk redet also sagen wir mal wirklich ein.
Unternehmen was eine it-infrastruktur mit vielleicht tausenden von diensten betreibt.
Durchaus möglich ist nötig ist und standardmäßig gemacht wird dass man halt ein mann dessous durchlaufen lässt also eine automatisierten scanner oder mal leute wie.
Ja penter oder auch mal mich dahin bestellt und sagt okay guck dich doch mal hier im netz um sag mal was du so findest an problemen und fehlern und.
Das soll also jetzt auch quasi das dürfen für die bundesrepublik deutschland mit dem ziel.
Natürlich dann eine art von ja warnung notification oder sonstigen herauszugeben so und jetzt.
In der berichterstattung die ich bisher so gehört habe.
Finden sich dann so begriffe wie ja das ist aber jetzt hier die superbehörde bs und das bis kriegt jetzt die.
Hacking lizenz und so weiter und wenn wenn der linus das mit dem internet macht dann darf der das nicht.
Aber das soll das jetzt dürfen das ist die lizenz zum hacken und so ne.
Und da muss ich sagen da hab ich glaube ich eine eine zwiegespaltenes meinung weil.
Das eigentliche problem ist nicht das zu tun weil wenn man das mit reinem gewissen und dem ziel schwachstellen.
Abzustellen macht dann ist das ja etwas positives denn wenn wir keine port scans machen und schwachstellen scans machen die angreifer machen das.
Da braucht man sich keine.
Braucht man sich nicht einzubilden dass das irgendjemand da draußen sitzt und sagt nee ich mache mal lieber keinen sport scannen weil darf ich nicht.
Das ist die alte hacker tools diskussion eigentlich ne.
Genau und das guter guter vergleich weil es jetzt nämlich hier bei den hacker tools die hacker tut's diskussion vielleicht kannst du die nochmal kurz zusammenfassen.
Ja das war ja so damals der erste vorstoß eigentlich in diesem bereich dass man so gesagt hat so internet ist gefährlich
und jetzt müssen wir den leuten bestimmte werkzeuge verbieten weil die sind ja gefährlich so und so nach dem motto bis bald kann man ja leute mit erschlagen darf man nicht mehr benutzen sollte halt versucht werden.
Deswegen der name hacker tools sozusagen den hackern das benutzen bestimmte programme zu verbieten nur wie du ihn jetzt auch schon ausgeführt hast ist es halt einfach kaum zu unterscheiden,
ob du ein werkzeug benutzt um,
sicherheit zu überprüfen oder um sicherheit zu umgehen ja du brauchst im prinzip dieselben schneidwerkzeug um zu schauen was ihr läuft und du hast so viel duell triple unendlich viel in so einem werkzeug das ist einfach
dass man nicht sagen kann diese software darf jetzt nicht verwendet werden weil es einfach unsinn.
Also genau ergebnis wäre dann in meiner arbeit ich hätte dann jetzt ich könnte den größeren teil der software die die ich für meine um meine arbeit vernünftig zu machen.
Die software könnte ich legal nicht mehr besitzen mit anderen worten ich könnte meine arbeit nicht mehr machen.
Und du hättest halt diese klassische situation von der die amerika vor dir die amerikaner mit ihren waffengesetzten ja immer warnen ist ganz only outlaws heft ganz also wenn wenn knarren verboten werden haben nur noch die kriminellen knarren.
Ja wo man jetzt als deutscher sagt genau und man kann sie ihn dann wegnehmen ja was die amerikaner aber noch nicht so ganz verstanden haben aber das wäre halt hier bei den bei den hackathons tatsächlich problematisch ne.
Und dieses ein also quasi ein ähnliches argument wie wird bemüht wenn man sagt na ja das bist soll das nicht machen soll solche scans nicht machen so.
Punkt der aber jetzt hier der wichtige ist denke ich der sehr viel entscheidendere ich glaube es ist sinnvoll solche scans zu machen,
aber aber aber aber wichtig ist aber es ist nicht sinnvoll dass irgendjemanden machen zu lassen der am ende an weisungen von horst seehofer gebunden ist oder
auch egal wer irgendeinen anderen innenminister.
Oder staatssekretär eines innenministers in der bundesrepublik deutschland die verteidigung.
Und auch der scan zum ziele der verteidigung muss unbedingt irgendwo aufgehängt sein in einem in einer behörde der man vollständig und vollends vertrauen kann weil sie ein.
Absolut eindeutigen.
Auftrag hat und ich weiß gar nicht also die unabhängigkeit des bsc ist eine ich weiß gar nicht wie alt die forderung ist die der c schon immer betont wahrscheinlich seit es das bsi gibt.
Geräte auf jeden fall hier auch schon seit anfang an davon.
Wir reden hier seit anfang an davon ich glaube ich habe schon bei meiner.
Mit der muttermilch hast du's aufgenommen.
Ich hasse der muttermilch aufgenommen ich glaube aber dass es auf jeden fall habe ich schon in mehreren stellungnahmen an den deutschen bundestag auch immer wieder geschrieben und das erste mal war glaube ich im ausschuss digitale agenda aber auch bei im prinzip
kannst du das jedes mal machen wenn irgendwo in dem gesetz bis vorkommt musst du sagen hier zack aus dem innenministerium rauslösen ne also haben wir auf jeden fall.
Fordern wir dass jedes mal und es macht eben auch sinn weil im bundesinnenministerium sitzt dann eben auch so jemand wie.
Hans-georg maaßen mit seinem bundesamt für verfassungsschutz und die
zieht es ja die eben quasi genau in die umgekehrte richtung arbeiten sollen das heißt man hat hier einen inhärenten interessenkonflikt weil man eben sagt naja einerseits wollen wir ja auch wir wollen ja selber hacken können,
und dann ist das halt schlecht wenn die leute die hecken verhindern sollen auch unter deiner agile arbeiten das war natürlich auch das problem mit dieser meldepflichten für schwachstellen dass man sich sagt na ja toll wenn jetzt das bsi nachher die schwachstellen hat und dann nach eigener
maßgabe damit umgeht.
Wer sagt denn dass die nicht nachher verpflichtet werden dass der zitiert zu sagen und dann ist quasi die schwachstelle die ich dahin gemeldet habe wird dann vom vom bsc der cities gegeben und die zieht es setzt sich dann gegen die eigene bevölkerung ein also quasi.
Wenn man ein sicherheitsbeauftragten muss der.
Und zweideutig und rein defensiv sein und wenn man an dieser defensiv ist ä t des sicherheitsbeauftragten rüttelt dann,
gerät man eben in diesem bereich man möchte selber angreifen man will das machen was ich hack back nennt aber in wirklichkeit halt offensives agieren im,
mitwirke mitteln im raum bedeutet und das führt nicht zu einer besseren it-landschaft sagen wir es mal so,
also ich denke dass so aktive scans hanni pots durchaus sinnvoll sind aber das unter keinen umständen eine solche fähigkeit im innenministerium angesiedelt werden sollte.
Kann man von mir aus einer public-private-partnership was weiß ich machen kann man irgendwie ein unsere forschungsinstitute in deutschland mit mit der,
möglichkeit versehen aber da hat man natürlich auch wieder das problem am ende brauchst du eine verantwortliche staatliche stelle und die darf eben nicht im innenministerium unterliegen das denke ich sehr,
kernpunkt kernproblem punkt hier mit dem und in seinen aktiven scans es gibt dann noch irgendwie so eine.
Vorgabe achtzehn monate speicherung von protokoll daten bei parlamentariern und behörden da muss ich jetzt noch mal gucken.
Also mein eindruck ist dass.
Du solange deine protokoll daten ja nicht unbedingt speichern darfst ohne einen anlass dafür zu geben ja also wenn ich jetzt ein webserver habe und ich schreibe würde da ein look schreiben was ja nicht mache aber ich würde das tun dann.
Muss ich das ja nach wenigen monaten gelöscht haben.
Und ich muss in der datenschutz auskunft erklären warum ich das überhaupt mache was meine berechtigung mein berechtigtes interesse ist das zu tun und so.
Und jetzt kommt der wenn man jetzt bei den behörden sagt nicht ihr könnt sondern ihr müsst achtzehn monate speichern ist hier natürlich die hoffnung im.
Angriffe später noch auflösen zu können ja und nicht auf einmal daran zu scheitern dass du erkennst naja die angreifer sind mindestens sechs monate drin.
Aber wie die reingekommen sind wissen wir nicht mehr oder seit wann sie drin sind wissen wir nicht mehr weil wir so lange keine loks haben.
Und das ist halt der teil der hier angegangen werden soll.
Hat man jetzt auch gerade mit dem einbruch in diese forschungszentren computer infrastruktur wo auch davon ausgegangen wird.
Oh ja das hatten wir gar nicht behandelt diese die supercomputer die gehackt wurden.
Nicht genau da ging man davon aus dass es ein halbes jahr schon soweit lief oder länger.
Und die sorge war was die sorge war dass die angreifer irgendwie gucken wollen wie wir impfstoffe errechnet wirklichkeit haben die einfach nur irgendwie bitcoin gemeint oder.
Ich weiß nicht unsere korona forschung wollten sie irgendwie auslesen angeblich hab da so meine zweifel dass das alles so digital so gespeichert ist da kommen wir ja noch zu.
Ok also hier eine längere speicherung von protokoll daten
auch wieder schwieriges hin und her ne also da wird dann auch argumentiert okay könnte eine
vorratsdatenspeicherung bedeuten weil wenn du das jetzt alles zusammenführst dann siehst du eben nicht nur die eine behörde für die sich bürger x y interessiert sondern alle und was er da gesucht hat und so weiter
kann ich auch erkennen dass das problematisch ist ich kann aber natürlich auch aus meiner beruflichen erfahrung in forensischen untersuchungen sagen da sind looks schon nicht.
Nicht blöd wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen angriff aufklären soll dann ist das schon nicht schlecht da lokfans zu haben weil sonst bist du halt wirklich ein bisschen im dunkeln also denke ich hier müsste.
Eigentlich und das das lässt sich ja problemlos machen dass du sagst okay ihr habt ihr ihr müsst eure looks aufbewahren aber ihr bewahrt die bitte dezentral auf und,
in euer logo date gehört dass sie halt was weiß ich nach den nach drei monaten verschlüsselt werden,
public private krypto und zwar so dass sie nur im rahmen einer forensik die vom was weiß ich bin ausgeht wieder entschlüsselt werden können solche sachen gehen ja alle aber haben die da halt nicht drin.
Dann sollen auch eine ganze menge unternehmensdaten an das bsi gehen also zum beispiel welche kritischen komponenten die benutzen,
und da würde eben natürlich eine weitreichende übersicht über die verhältnisse im land entstehen ja ja jetzt ist natürlich die andere frage wenn die noch nicht mal wissen was die irgendwas da irgendwie los ist dann wissen die natürlich auch nicht welche komponenten sie
testen müssten also für mich hängt hier sehr viel daran dass ich sagen würde tja.
Wenn ich dieser behörde denn vertrauen könnte dann wären diese ideen.
Was die jetzt als tätigkeitsfelder bekommen soll und so zumindest.
Aus einer perspektive der verteidigung nicht schlecht.
Also da kann ich nichts sagen dass macht keinen sinn diese daten braucht ihr nicht das fällt mir bei den meisten daten dann doch schwer was wir aber denke ich wie gesagt.
Wiederhole dem punkt nochmal dem innenministerium untergeordnet ist das ein no-go das ist leider ein problem und das führt uns jetzt natürlich in der behandlung dieses gesetzesentwurfes zu der.
Schwierigen sache dass wir jetzt.
Sachverständige in dem bereich im zweifelsfall sagen müssen oder nicht sagen können das ist unsinn ja beim it-sicherheitsgesetz eins war ich ja sachverständiger da habe ich ja zu vielen sachen gesagt pass auf dass es unsinn darf ich auch recht behalten,
dass die sachen die ich da als unsinnig bezeichnet habe haben sich nicht herausgestellt als gangbar und sinnvoll aber.
In diesem fall muss ich sagen aus einer technischen perspektive sind das mit dann doch durchaus sinnvolle ideen.
Aus einer gesellschaftlichen perspektive sind das aber problematische ideen und jetzt muss man sich halt überlegen wie kriegen wir das hin dass die gesellschaftlichen probleme.
Nicht bekommen wenn wir die technische sinnvollen lösungen und herangehensweisen hier umsetzen.
Das denke ich ist mein vorsichtiger blick auf das,
it-sicherheitsgesetz zwei null zu dem wir als c und sicherlich auch noch detaillierter äußern werden.
Schon detailliert geäußert habt ihr euch ja aber auch schon gegenüber dem neuen patientendatensätze schutzgesetz was wir hier auch schon ein paar mal behandelt haben.
Ja insbesondere hatten wir ja hier zebra und martin nochmal in der in der sendung vor wenigen wochen.
Genau und dazu gibt's jetzt aber eine offizielle stellungnahme.
Genau es hat uns aus dem gesundheitsausschuss die
anfrage erreicht doch eine sachverständigen auskunft zu dem geplanten patienten datenschutzgesetz zu formulieren
ist natürlich klar so eine anfrage habe ich dann freundlich den martin gebeten ob er das denn machen würde hat der martin gemacht er hatte sich ja wie man in der sendung gehört hat ohnehin schon im detail mit dem gesetz auseinander
gesetzt und die stellungnahme veröffentlichen wir dann auch heute.
Spezifisch geht's dabei im prinzip um eine sache es gab diesen vortrag hacker hin oder her die elektronische patientenakte kommt in der martin,
februar ja diese schwachstellen demonstriert haben in der in dem erlangen von zugangs karten und da.
Hat dann ich glaube ein team war das da die mussten ja dann nachvollziehen bestätigen die haben sich ja dann irgendwie so einen arzt ausweis von jemand anders in irgendein supermarkt an die käsetheke
liefern lassen und nur um zu zeigen wie kaputt dieser prozess ist jetzt wäre natürlich ein paar patienten datenschutzgesetz genau die möglichkeit gewesen.
Diese schwachstellen abzug abzustellen und eben zu sagen aha die,
bei der beantragung und auch bei der ausstellung bei der übergabe müssen saubere identifikation stattfinden.
Und er ist leider diese chance verstreicht leider und,
ich kann jetzt hier kurz aus der stellungnahme des c,
zitieren wir stellen fest dass der vorliegende gesetzentwurf nicht geeignet ist die diagnostizierten mängel sowie die ursächlichen fehlanreize abzustellen erstens die elektronische gesundheitskarte wird weiterhin unsicher und ohne zuverlässige
identitätspolitik der antragsteller ausgegeben statt die mängel unter deren ausnutzung der zugriff auf gesundheitsdaten dritter gelingt abzustellen werden diese nunmehr sogar
gesetzlich festgeschrieben also der mangel war vorher war es ein mangel jetzt ist es gesetzliche vorgabe.
Und zweitens die bislang nicht erfolgte umsetzung der bestehenden gesetzlichen vorgaben wird weiterhin nicht
ausreichend sanktioniert krankenkassen als herausgeber der elektronischen gesundheitskarte bleiben im gegensatz zu arztpraxen von den sanktionen der dsgvo ausgenommen,
trotzdem sollen krankenkassen zukünftig mit erlaubnis des versicherten die gesundheitsdaten der patientenakte verarbeiten dürfen.
Hier übrigens ne der entscheidende punkt die dsgvo ist vor exakt zwei jahren in kraft getreten wobei ich mir nicht ich glaube die dsgvo ist.
Wie war das denn nochmal da es ist nämlich auch genau zwei jahre her dass wir logbuch netzpolitik zweihundertsechsundfünfzig gemacht haben,
ich gucke gerade an mir herab und man sieht ich ich kann kaum noch sprechen wenn ich aber herab gucke weil der aufdruck so schön oben ist ich mag die aufdruck ja immer schön hoch ich habe mich das zweihundertsechsundfünfzig shirt.
Was soll ich dachte weil er so dick geworden bist in der cola zeit.
Nein nein ja durchsetzt ja hier ich ernähre mich ja nur noch von lieferando und sitzt auf und gehe auf dem balkon auf und ab nein.
Ich habe das shirt an und da haben wir ja genau mit dem.
Jan philipp-albrecht auch über die dsgvo besprochen kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf also patienten datenschutzgesetz erfüllt die erwartungen die man an gesundheitsminister spahn.
Hat.
Und es gibt aber auch neuigkeiten im bereich der contact tracing sachen tim was haben wir da neues.
Na ja also so viel neues gibt es erstmal eigentlich nicht aber immerhin gab es jetzt die lange erwarteten betriebssystem releases von apple und von
google bei google weiß ich nicht ganz genau auf welche version zumal das gerade hinaus lief aber die haben das über diese places aus
ausgeschieden weil ich grade sagen ausgespielt.
Die ansage war ursprünglich dass es bis andere sechs gehen könnte
da habe ich jetzt noch keine bestätigung dafür bei apple hält man sich da ganz frisch und hat das sozusagen nur in das aller aller neueste betriebssystem release dreizehn fünf reingehauen und das bedeutet dass jetzt die programmiert stellen vorhanden sind um solche.
Tatsächlich auf diesen telefon laufen zu lassen
also die mit dem dezentralen modell das modell auf das deutschland und viele andere länder mittlerweile auch setzen das wird jetzt überhaupt erst ausrollen
fähig man könnte also im prinzip heute oder hätte jetzt letzte woche als rauskam damit beginnen können.
Das finde ich einen sehr wichtigen punkt weil.
Also erstens das heißt eine contact tracing app eine funktionierende contact tracing app ist jetzt seit wenigen tagen zumindest mal theoretisch möglich.
Also sagen wir mal so
entwickeln konnte man sich schon vorher und es wird ja auch getan und wurde auch getan nur dritten also uns allen zugänglich ist es erst ab jetzt
dass wir jetzt nicht gleich mit diesem tag
ein release gesehen haben hängt damit zustande dass es eben nicht nur auf diese komponente ankommt sondern eben auch noch auf viele andere komponenten die zusammenspielen müssen und vor allem muss das ganze dann eben auch noch etwas breiter getestet werden.
Die zeit war natürlich ohnehin relativ
knapp wir haben das ja hier über die wochen letzten monaten begleitet und es gab immer wieder neue erkenntnisse und da musst du auch erstmal der politische battle gewonnen werden und das team auf dass es jetzt halt
zukommt diese arbeit die die ist ja da auch dran und die haben auch schon diverse code teile veröffentlicht auf gitarre ist das alles jetzt einsehbar das ist da auch noch nicht fertig,
aber es existiert und vor allem haben sie sich relativ viel mühe gegeben,
die details der system architektur diese geplant haben akribisch zu dokumentieren ich finde das ist auch alles sehr ordentlich gemacht worden.
Ja vor allem muss man sagen sie haben auch eine sache die ich sehr interessant fand die hatten quasi ihr developer report
das war offenbar dann halt vorher nicht öffentlich und die haben aber das report auch mit der community story glaube ich online gestellt das heißt du hast nicht nur irgendwie das ist es jetzt sondern wenn du möchtest kannst du in dem.
Quasi auch zurückgehen und gucken was in welcher richtung die das entwickelt haben ja das das finde ich schon.
Ist auch nicht üblich siehst sieht man auch öfter mal anders sagen wir so.
Ja also man man merkt dass da ein team am start ist die also nicht nur open source verstanden haben also das sind einfach leute die machen das nicht das erste mal und das eben auch viele entscheidungen,
im prinzip so gefällt worden wie wir das auch tun würden also es ist einfach eine korrekte offenheit bis hierhin,
ich habe das natürlich jetzt noch nicht laufen sehen weil läuft halt nicht und gibt halt diese app nicht nur man kann es sich halt anschauen und man kann auf basis des systems designs für sich entscheiden,
macht es so sinn ist das ist das so wie es hier,
konzipiert ist wie die server aufteilung ist wer wann wem wo welche message schickt was hier womit verschlüsselt ist und wie die abfolgen sind macht es sinn macht es sinn aus einem
ablauf macht es sinn für die user letzten endes macht es sinn aus einer sicherheit denke heraus
und soweit habe ich bisher wenig konkrete kritik gehört das ist eigentlich eher so dass alle sagen ja ist noch nicht fertig aber soweit,
erstmal nichts dran zu meckern.
Ja du hast auch keinen fall die erwartung wäre ja im prinzip du veröffentlichst sowas und,
in innerhalb von vierundzwanzig stunden kommt irgend so ein art,
der ist ausgeblieben und das ist glaube ich dass das über die erwartungen.
Das ist ein gutes zeichen.
Aus positiv ich wollte noch ein aspekt dazu benennen weil ich jetzt ja auch seit einigen wochen zum glück etwas
etwas zurück gelernter mir die berichterstattung über diese contact racing sachen anschauen kann weil es eben nichts mehr zu berichten gibt und ich deswegen die oder weil es gerade nicht viel zu berichten gibt ich deswegen halt auch presse anfragen,
ja unbeantwortet lasse oder sagt gibt ich habe nichts neues zu erzählen sucht euch jemand anderes vielleicht haben die was neues zu erzählen der tenor in der presse war in den letzten wochen.
So die letzten zwei wochen ungefähr so.
Wo bleibt unsere app wo bleibt unsere app die anderen haben längst die bundesregierung verschläft wieder dinge die digitalisierung und so weiter ja und.
Schwenkte dann in der letzten woche um auf,
seht her seither die apps die die anderen haben bringen überhaupt nichts ja und da werden jetzt die unterschiedlichen staaten.
Ich habe das über singapur gelesen ich habe das über australien gelesen die schon contact tracing apps gebastelt hatten,
die wie wir alle wissen nicht funktionieren konnten,
sinnvoll weil sie eben massive einschränkungen haben dadurch dass sie im hintergrund sind also im prinzip contact tracing apps die du aktiv im vordergrund halten musst
und die haben jetzt stellt sich heraus die haben nicht die gewünschten oder die erwarteten ergebnisse geliefert ja auch das ist eben auch nicht überraschend ja das ist.
Muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen fand ich in der medialen berichterstattung nicht überzeugend weil wir schon.
Eigentlich es hätte sage ich mal den geneigten journalistinnen durchaus.
Erkennbar gemacht worden sein können dass eben tatsächlich das was hier diskutiert wird
und was unter realbedingungen funktionieren kann und soll tatsächlich erst mit diesen updates überhaupt möglich wird und wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe es gibt's in lettland jetzt so eine app jetzt kann man sich lettland angucken ja kann man gucken ob das ob und wie das da funktioniert.
Ja und die schweiz wird jetzt wohl auch relativ zügig releasen also die sind ja schon ein bisschen länger auf das dezentrale modell eingeschworen und am ende hängt das natürlich auch damit zusammen,
das muss man bei diesem ganzen ding aussehen diese fixierung auf die app auf dem telefon ja das ist
eine komponente aber die weitaus schwierigere komponente weil das was auf dem telefon läuft ist verhältnismäßig einfach das was daran schwer ist das haben einen apple und google eigentlich schon abgenommen man muss eigentlich nur noch daten durchreichen und ein bisschen besser interface draufkleben und keine groben fehler machen
das ist nicht das ding das problem ist die anbindung,
an die gesundheitsinformation struktur und wie man diese anbindung machen will und in deutschland hat man sich dafür entschlossen und das finde ich auch eine ganz
dass diese app eben einem auch den test zustellt das heißt in dem moment wo man sich testen lässt kann man beide ab
gabe der proben schon eine idee erhalten für diesen test das telefon weiß sozusagen schon drauf es wartet und wenn dieses testergebnis da ist bekommt man das direkt auf die app geliefert und dann steht da drauf,
testergebnis so sieht's aus und wenn's halt positiv war kann man in dem moment dann sofort auch seine kies veröffentlichen sodass es eben auch maximal schmeckt.
Ich muss das noch ganz kurz ich wollte weil das die anbindung an die gesundheitsinformation struktur nur nochmal um das du hast das so impliziert genannt in jedem land gibt es ja unterschiedliche,
zum beispiel regularien und reife der it- und prozesse wie solche testergebnisse gemeldet und zurückgemeldet werden und,
das ist das ich habe das glaube ich hier vor ein paar wochen im logbuch sein das ist das heavy lifting,
was apple dann hier nämlich die anpassung an die nationalen regularien infrastrukturen und so weiter das überlassen die den app-entwicklern ja und das ist nicht wenig und was wir hier in dem deutschen entwurf für die app sehen.
Ist auch nicht nicht so einfach und so schnell gebaut aber die haben letztendlich sag mal in dem modernsten,
testzentrum wäre das wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe so du lässt dich testen und du kriegst dann schon r code mit nach hause,
der quasi die idee deines tests ist und du kannst dann quasi online in der app.
Aktiv dein testergebnis abrufen oder eine notification also oder der ruft einmal am tag oder mehrmals am tag automatisch ab ja also,
entweder du also.
So läuft es das telefon fragt regelmäßig nach dem ergebnis.
Telefon genau das die beste beschreibung das telefon fragt regelmäßig nach dem ergebnis,
alle telefone fragen regelmäßig nach einem ergebnis auch die die gar kein test aufstehen haben um nämlich zu,
ja den den nicht am traffic erkennbar zu machen dass du gerade einen test gemacht hast und gerade ein ergebnis bekommen hast und so weiter und so fort und.
Jetzt quasi dafür zu sorgen,
jetzt hast du ja quasi dann auch bewiesen dass du berechtigt bist oder du hast jetzt ein beweis dass du berechtigt bist dich krank zu melden weil man muss ja diese trolling resistenz da reinbringen und dann diese prozesse mussten ja definiert werden.
Inklusive ihrer potenziellen paper four wurde jetzt von mir aus bei einem labor ein test machst dass diese art der digitalen anbindung noch nicht hat und dann eben das gesundheitsamt anruft und eine
telefon pin gibt mit der du telefon tannen gibt mit der du jetzt einmalig deine dingens melden kannst und so das ist alles.
In dem architektur dokument drin da geht einiges.
Da gibt's eine hotline da musst du leute haben die die das beim gesundheitsamt machen und dann nochmal so eine separate hotline leute probleme mit der app aber also da gehört sehr viel mehr dazu und das entsteht jetzt alles und,
wir wissen nicht genau wann es kommt ich vermute mal wir werden so mitte juni wahrscheinlich so ein,
punkt erreicht haben wo das eigentlich alles zusammen laufen könnte wenn's.
Sollte.
Wenn's gut läuft gibt es vielleicht sogar schon erstmal so eine stumme version der app vorher zwei wochen vorher weil dann könnten nämlich zumindest schon mal alle anfangen,
überhaupt erstmal kies zu sammeln sonst müsste man ja nochmal warten bis das überhaupt alles,
voll wird das wird sich alles zeigen und parallel dazu entwickelt sich halt auch jetzt gerade eine größere debatte darüber,
wie man denn jetzt international arbeiten soll also was ist mit wenn andere leute wenn leute in andere länder gehen und dort leute aus den ländern oder aus
dritten ländern treffen und wenn die halt zusammen rumhängen wie kann man die denn waren weil das dann sozusagen so eine knifflige frage wie dann der data flow ist.
Ja aber die sehe ich nicht so knifflig muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen also da können sie gerne darüber tanken technisch sehe ich das nicht knifflig
ja das war eine der eines der argumente wo was ja immer für den zentralen ansatz gesagt wurde ja wir können aber hier direkt in ganz europa agieren ich sehe keine trifftigen gründe warum das.
Zwischen den europäischen ländern auch im dezentralen ansatz nicht nicht nicht funktionieren sollte.
Also es geht ja auch explizit so also das ist jetzt eher eine frage wie macht man es konkret so weil,
teilweise hast du halt ein modell wo du dann vom vom goodwill und von der informiert hat der user ausgehen muss und andere machen vielleicht ein bisschen automatisiert also ich rechne ehrlich gesagt mittelfristig mit einer eu-weiten lösung aber dazu müssen halt noch ein paar länder umfallen
vor allem frankreich die sich halt bisher immer noch an ihrem zentralen modell festbeißen und dann irgendwann halt feststellen werden dass sie scheitern.
Ja aber das aber das haben wir ja auch schon besprochen dass der das problem von frankreich mit seinem zentralen modell ist nicht die eu sondern apple und google ja die müssen sich jetzt halt mit einer technischen realität anfreunden die,
jetzt mal ob ob das gut oder schlecht ist nun mal da ist und von apple google definiert wurde ja da sehe ich also tut mir dann tut mir jetzt leid
dieses mal haben apple und google ebene entscheidungen getroffen die ich gut heiße
und da muss ich jetzt frankreich mal mit anfreunden passiert oft genug dass apple google der entscheidung treffen die ich nicht gut halte heiße und frankreich auch gar keine probleme hat sich damit anzufangen also
diesmal spielt tanzt es eben andersrum ich denke die erwartungshaltung hast du ja gerade auch schon gesagt so mitte juni.
Für eine deutsche app ist.
Kann hoffentlich im realistischen rahmen bleiben bleiben insbesondere wenn man wie du gerade vorgeschlagen hast sagt man nimmt.
Komponenten einzeln also es hatte sich ja glaube ich eh schon gezeigt dass.
Diese komponente telemetrie nachzuliefern also quasi die,
die datenspeicher in anführungszeichen noch mit dran das kommt erst später also hier scheint schon so ein modulares vorgehen stattzufinden und dann ist denke ich nämlich.
Dann sind dann wäre deutschland irgendwas wie drei wochen oder vier wochen nach veröffentlichung nach ausrollen der epic dran und die uhr für die entwicklung lief erst ab grün donnerstag beziehungsweise wenn wir ehrlich sind ab,
oster dienstag ja dass man damit beginnen konnte und deswegen finde ich dieses gesamte geschrei die anderen haben aber schon eine und jetzt das geschrei die bei den anderen funktioniert das aber nicht dass es.
Ja bedauerlich eine bedauerliche entwicklung weil das eben tatsächlich beides nicht wirklich.
Zu ziehende schlussfolgerungen waren aus der aus der sachlage.
Apropos nicht zu ziehen es schlussfolgerungen tim das ist dort aber eine überleitung oder.
Noch ist sie nicht fertig ja.
Twitter hat gerade eine eine eine schöne große auseinandersetzung die ich hier nicht unerwähnt lassen möchte und die ja auch schon unser intro.
Beehrt geehrt und geprägt hat und zwar ist ja jetzt schon seit längerer zeit so dass der christian trosten,
der,
psychologe der charité der ja mit seinem podcast den korona update eine sehr große reichweite auch erzielt hat innerhalb kürzester zeit.
Jetzt wirklich fast wöchentlich,
kritik an den medien übt was den umgang mit bestimmten studienergebnisse angeht was,
den umgang mit seiner person angeht und ich muss sagen ich finde das ja immer sehr,
ja so ein bisschen putzig wieder die kritik übt weil er.
Also man merkt so richtig wie er emotional wird und sagt so das ist überhaupt nicht fundiert und das ist ungehörig finde ich sehr schön.
Finde ich super ja wie er sich eben auch nicht auf das wie er sich da nicht von seinem niveau herunterreißen lässt.
Welcome to world.
Schaffe strenge worte und dann jetzt,
gibt es dann jetzt auch dann fühlen sich immer der ein oder andere journalist oder journalistin auch bemüht sigt dem dann zu widersprechen und zu sagen dem trosten steht keine kritik an uns medien zu was ich dann auch sehr unterhaltsam finde.
Und ich kann jetzt zum beispiel so aus meiner perspektive als einer der ehrenamtlichen sprecher des c ja auch sagen dass ich ja auch regelmäßig.
In der presse,
verlautbarungen lese die dann mal ja wo vielleicht etwas was wir sagen in falschen kontext gerissen wird oder die einen sachverhalt falsch darstellen und ich mich darüber ärgere und ich bin in der regel.
Ja also bisschen aus einer professionalität heraus aber auch aus einer strategie halt zu sagen na ja nächstes mal hochzeit dass es besser machen aber auch durch einen kräfteverhältnis und eine auch eine abhängigkeit unsere
c pressearbeit ist natürlich auch von den medien abhängig das ist ja eine pressearbeit sehr zurückhaltend mit dieser kritik,
in der vorletzten sendung wo dann die faz sich einfach so dermaßen also so dermaßen nachvollziehbar und belegbar dämlich geäußert hat oder diese drei pseudonymen autorin und diese sind ja bei der motor und sorry.
Hatten da habe ich dann mal auch mal wie ich es selten mache.
Meine ausführliche kritik geübt in eine ausführliche rezension vorgenommen und der trosten hat jetzt hier etwas gemacht was ich
eigentlich täglich machen könnte nämlich eine völlig lächerliche und ungehörige presse anfrage einfach mal getwittert und gesagt hier guckt guckt euch das mal an und diese presse anfrage
kommt von einem herrn mit dem namen philipp pia tore der aus dem politik resort von bild ihm schreibt mir
dem satz wir berichten über die kritik mehrerer wissenschaftler an ihrer studie
über die virus konzentration bei verschiedenen altersgruppen dazu bitte ich sie um eine kurzfristige stellungnahme bis heute um sechzehn uhr die e-mail ist abgesendet um fünfzehn uhr also exakt eine stunde zeit gibt er dem.
Und da hat er einige beispiele der kritischen stimmen gibt dann so eine auflistung von vier professoren unterschiedlicher universitäten die.
Die schwachpunkte der studie benennen und zwar dieser studie jetzt muss man natürlich sagen dass ist nicht irgendeine studie sondern virus konzentration bei verschiedenen altersgruppen.
Die also guckt auch ne wie.
Wie viel virus ist in so einem kind drin und diese frage wie viel virus ist in so einem kind drin infektionsweg kind ist gesellschaftlich in deutschland eine relativ wichtige frage weil die natürlich mit den.
Kita schließungen zusammenhängt großmutter kann großmutter jetzt auf das kind aufpassen oder nicht und ist halt eine wissenschaftlich sehr wichtige frage mit sehr,
weitreichende konsequenzen deswegen kümmert sich jetzt hier filip biathlon,
der laut linkedin oder wo ich das gefunden habe hat auf meinung ist ja also das ist der der,
der leiter des meinungs- ressorts bei der bild.
Wohl bemerkt dass ist das resort für meinung nicht für meinungen ja und man kann sich natürlich vorstellen man kann sich natürlich vorstellen was was die hier im schilde führen.
Und gestern gab es ein riesen theater schon um um diesen tweet von.
Von von droste weil der frechheit hier die die die anfrage des journalisten angriffe auf die freiheit der journalisten und und haste nicht gesehen er hatte persönliche daten von diesem,
pia natur veröffentlicht sehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht also sehe ich in diesem ding nicht aber es kann sein dass es irgendeinen anderen tret oder so war keine ahnung ich,
vielleicht habe ich das übersehen.
Ich glaube es gab nur den einen tweet die regen sich einfach erstmal auf weil sie weil sie einfach auch ordentlich flag bekommen haben und glaube ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr in die fresse bekommen haben als sie es normalerweise gewohnt sind.
Und weißt du wieso tim weil der drostersen die nicht braucht
und der nämlich einfach mal hingehen kann und der hat keiner der hat der braucht nicht in der öffentlichkeit zu stehen der macht das als hobby der würde lieber ins labor gehen und der der baut auch keine langfristige
sage ich mal also jetzt wenn ich im c was öffentlich sagen muss ich das ja einbinden in einem mehr oder weniger langfristige strategie.
Dieser organisation im im öffentlichen diskurs,
ja ich kann mir nicht mit dir ich kann's mir nicht mit jedem dummen journalisten verscherzen ein paar kann ich mir erlauben aber nicht alle ja weil ich diese diese organisation irgendwie am leben halten muss und der.
Trosten ist vollkommen frei davon ja der kann sagen irgendwann ist dieser corona kram vorbei dann gehe ich zurück in mein
keller zu den anderen viren und bis zur nächsten pandemien lasst ihr mich alle in ruhe und ich kann meine arbeit weitermachen ich bin wirklich kann wirklich mal auf euch scheißen und das ist bei den wenigsten die in öffentlicher berichterstattung vorkommen der fall,
ja dass sie wirklich mal sagen können komm,
ist mir doch egal ja und also so wirklich mit aller konsequenz ich mache das ja schon so gut wie es geht aber mit aller konsequenz kann's halt eher machen.
Ja also das ist bei ihm natürlich ein faktor dass dass er so ein bisschen diese egal also ich glaube nicht dass es ihm wirklich egal ist so aber.
Nein ganz im gegenteil du merkst ja der der der bebt ja richtig.
Der bebt schon so aber er er hat oder ich würde sogar fast schon sagen er ist mittlerweile auch schon selbst öffentlichkeit,
und er also ob das ein twitterkanal ist oder so dann später wenn er sich dann auch nochmal im
sichert mit sicherheit dazu äußern wird ja und auch mit seiner wunderbaren empörten,
unterton aber trotzdem trocken einfach nur die fakten durchrasseln sich dazu äußern wird und dass er er hat halt ein vertrauensverhältnis zu öffentlichkeit aufgebaut was eben auch eine bildzeitung,
nicht so ohne weiteres einreisen kann und ich glaube das ist auch das was die bild gerade so ärgert
dass sie an der stelle ein bisschen so ihr ihre ihre deutungshoheit einbüßt natürlich nicht universell und viele werden das lesen und werden wieder verstört sein und anfangen zu schreien und so weiter das ist das was die bildzeitung normalerweise bedient
aber so die meinung dadurch dann auch komplett zu dominieren das gelingt ihnen gerade nicht so richtig.
Und deswegen haben sie dann eben jetzt also diese haben sie dann jetzt irgendwie heute auf der titelseite offenbar dann sowieso hier star virolent loge wird von internationalen kollegen
kritisiert oder so studie ist unsinnig mit anderen worten die bild will sich gerade warmschießen für macht die kitas wieder auf und,
tatsächlich ist das ja auch ich habe das ja auch in der letzten sendung genannt,
die kids jeder tag schließung dieser kitas ist eine unglaubliche belastung für alleinerziehende eltern für gemeinsam erziehende eltern und das ist ein riesenproblem ja nur hier muss eben,
genau deswegen muss er hier nicht irgendeine entscheidung getroffen werden sondern die richtige und zu diesen richtigen entscheidungen trägt eben der christian droste genauso bei,
wie unterschiedliche forscherinnen und forscher die diese studie einordnen,
um der wissenschaftlichen community die lücken zu zeigen oder aufzuzeigen die die interpretation der studie schwächen und die,
der grund sind weitere zu machen
so funktioniert die wissenschaft man guckt sich die die studien man guckt dann an wie kann diese studie noch besser gemacht werden oder welche fragen lässt diese studie offen und wie kann ich diese wie kann ich mich diesen fragen vielleicht nähern
nun ja.
Bild veröffentlicht also jetzt sein auf auf seite eins schieße sich jetzt auf den trosten ein viel spaß dabei und der spiegel.
Veröffentlicht einen artikel der quasi sagt wir wir fragen einfach mal die zitierten wissenschaftler die standen ja hier in der mail die der die der trosten als screenshot veröffentlicht hat und.
Fragen mal was die dazu sagen ja und diese wissenschaftler sagen.
Du ich habe keine ahnung mich hat diese bild nicht gefragt den hätte ich was anderes gesagt es scheint dass die irgendwie eine satz aus irgendeinem preparing von mir veröffentlichen indem ich mal kurz eine methodische schwäche dieser studie diskutiere,
die der trosten aber selber in der studie disco diskutiert ich sehe nur für meinen kontext nochmal betonen ja und,
jetzt kommt das schönste jetzt meldet sich denn julian der verantwortliche redakteur politik.
Und wirft wirklich seine gesamte argumentative schärfe und rhetorische gewandt halt in die waagschale mit dem tweet,
sorry der spiegel was für ein dreck was für ein verhör was für ein nehmen sie ihre kritik an droste zu druck zurück weil weil,
weil bild sie nutzt was für tendenziösen fragen was für ein billiger missbrauch der paragraf rasiert unseres kollegen korinthenkacker und dann hat er irgendwie noch zwei mileys dahin gemacht einen kotzendes.
Ja also das ist irgendwie so so könnte mit kritik umgehen und ich kann ich muss wirklich sagen.
Habe fertig was willst du da noch sagen was sind das für erbärmliche kreaturen die sich irgendwie die
die die sich so eure müssen die sich die blöße geben ja so zu reagieren wenn ihre methoden mit denen sie ja bei allen anderen leuten problemlos durchkommen üblicherweise läuft das ja so die bild sagt jemandem sage sack in einer stunde.
Ich will eine stellungnahme innerhalb einer stunde machen die aus zwei gründen erstens in der einen stunde kannst du keine vernünftige antwort formulieren,
damit sie dir die nämlich reinwirken können zweitens schreiben sie die mail um fünfzehn uhr damit sie eigentlich darauf hoffen wenn du nämlich keine antwort mehr schaffst dass sie die nämlich auch nicht mehr drucken müssen
das ist die methode die hier anwendung findet die studie von droste ist irgendwo aus dem april.
Und auch diese kritiken oder einordnung von anderen wissenschaftlern die sind ja nicht alle gestern gekommen da hat einfach dieser meinungs- einfach mal
irgendwie auf dem prinz server der falsche suchbegriff eingegeben und hat sich die hände gekriegen und weil
wir solche medien haben in deutschland führen wir unsere diskurse so,
arsch wie wir sie führen und deswegen sieht der tier auch so aus wenn du dir diese spinner am alexanderplatz oder sonst wo anschaust weil hier wirklich keine sinnvolle auseinandersetzung.
Mehr stattfindet und ich möchte nochmal betonen es geht hier um einen den umgang mit einer
unerforschten situation und wir werden deswegen habe ich das eingangs gesagt wir werden feststellen hoffentlich feststellen dass einige der ergriffen maßnahmen,
zu drastisch waren und durch mildere ersetzt werden können und das ist gut und das ziel ist nicht jetzt irgendwelche leute darüber zu ruinieren dass sie studien gemacht haben die uns dabei helfen sollen die richtigen entscheidungen zu treffen.
Hallo,
ehrlich was ist das was ist das für ein für ein ekelhaftes geschwür diese art der der diskussion in in deutschland zu führen es ist unverantwortlich und ungehörig.
Ja die sollen sich sollten sie mal auskotzen was man auch merkt ist meine auf der einen seite wenn ich mir so einen kommentar wie von dem röcke anschaue denke ich mir so.
Wieso man auch schon meinte so beschreibt doch eigentlich eure eigenen methoden so wie verloren ist jetzt bitte dieses statement aber auf der anderen seite was für mich da auch noch so ein bisschen raussucht ist.
Wahrscheinlich merken die es in dem moment gar nicht mal die sind aber auch auf ihrem privileg der deutungshoheit so eingesessen,
dass sie noch nicht mal mehr merken wenn sie schon links und rechts einige schaller bekommen und eigentlich auch schon
schon bluten und trotzdem nochmal in den ring wollen und das könnte nochmal ganz lustig werden ich verlinke nochmal dazu ist nämlich gerade auch vor kurzem glaube ich erst verfügbar geworden eine,
alte doku vor aus den siebzigern wo günther wallraff inkognito mal bei der bild als redakteur anheuert und da reinschauen.
Oder wie hat es nicht.
Weiß ich grad nicht.
Mann bei.
Informationen aus dem hinterland.
Vom wdr das haben sie lange zeit unter verschluss gehalten wurde damals nicht gesendet und kam irgendwie erst später raus aber das da kann man dann schon mal sehen auch sehr interessant ich habe noch nicht ganz durchgeschaut aber.
Moment das waren war das nicht ein buch der mann der bei bild hans esser war.
Das kann sein dass er da auch ein buch draus gemacht hat auf jeden fall gibt's halt 'ne richtige halbstündige doku wo das alles
gefilmt wird und wo man so sieht wie sich weirauch darauf vorbereitet und dir dann auch so gedankenprotokoll mäßig wieso berichtet wie wir langsam da auch
ins hirn gefräst bekommt ja und mal so ich muss mich da jetzt richtig reinfallen lassen ich muss jetzt so richtig so scheiße werden wie die sonst sonst sonst sonst sonst kann ich das erstmal gar nicht
so mitgehen wenn ich mich von anfang an dagegen wäre und so weiter dann dann dann werde ich die nicht so richtig,
kann ich ja nicht in meinen auftrag dass mal so richtig zu ergründen wie es da läuft nicht nicht nicht durchziehen.
Es waren sogar zwei bücher die er geschrieben hat der aufmacher und zeugen der anklage.
Hat er über seine zeit als hans-peter geschrieben wobei weil er kürzlich verstorben ist
das auch erwähnung finden sollte dass der hermann litzer gesagt hat dass er quasi der weiter von der aufmacher war.
Bei wer verstorben ist.
Hermann der herausgeber also wahl spiegel redakteur bitte was hat herausgegeben.
Ich habe nur gerade das so verstanden als ob du meinen würdest das güter weirauch verstorben ist.
Nein nein nein nein gremlin ist anfang des jahres verstorben glaube ich oder ende letzten jahres ja.
Ein meinungsstark journalistin deutschland herausgeber der monats zeitschrift konkret bis zuletzt gewesen.
Aber okay.
Genau weil bei der bild-zeitung und ich meine ich glaube man kann bei dieser sache diese ganzen sachen das war ja ende siebziger anfang achtziger.
Und meine herren ich meine diese bildzeitung hat sich jetzt wirklich seitdem nicht unbedingt verbessert.
Nicht auf jeden fall.
Sind sich auf jeden fall treu geblieben diese die sind sich treu geblieben und haben sich weiterentwickelt das muss man kann man denn auf jeden fall so sagen.
Naja also das ist wirklich eine eine vergiftung,
der gesellschaftlichen auseinandersetzung und für für diese für dieses niveau der auseinandersetzung für diese art der in anführungszeichen journalistischen aber ganz sicher nicht zu journalistischen und in
da haben wir in dieser gesellschaft einfach gerade keinen platz für das muss man einfach so sagen und deswegen ist das auch wirklich
also den satz ich habe besseres zu tun der ist ja selten war,
das ist ja arbeit trosten glaube ich ist der wirklich wahr der hat wirklich besseres zu tun als irgend so ein,
bildlich zu antworten machen wir übrigens auch nie.
Hallo.
Nein macht man nicht.
So wir haben nur noch wenig zeit lass uns noch die letzten beiden themen durchziehen.
Ja die die dsgvo vor zwei jahren,
beschlossen vor zwei jahren in kraft getreten und da wird gibt es natürlich jetzt allerlei wortmeldungen zum jahr jubiläum.
Und ich denke der einer der wichtigsten einschätzen begriff einschätzen einsätze kommt hier von access selbst das beste gesetz der welt nutzt wenig wenn es nicht umgesetzt wird max schrems
hat sich beschwert bei der irischen datenschutzbeauftragten hellen dicksten.
Weil in irland mit dem traditionell günstigen datenschutz und auch steuerlich nicht nachteiliges situationen sitzen ja facebook twitter und google und,
er sagt bei ihr liegen eigentlich zwölf große fälle gegen diese großen big data unternehmen an doch in den zwei jahren hat sie.
Kaum etwas über den unternommen um diese geschäftspraktiken der daten konzerne einzuschränken ganz im gegenteil max unterstellt sogar die leisten aktive hilfe bei der umgehung.
Der datenschutzgrundverordnung beziehungsweise der european data protection director heißt das ja dann glaube ich ne.
Und in der reaktion haben die irischen datenschützer jetzt eine härtere gangart angekündigt.
Aber man muss natürlich auch feststellen es gab ja auch eine ganze menge warnungen wie gefährlich das alles mit der dsgvo wird.
Das war auch bei unserer live-sendung so ein bisschen auch mit das thema hier abmahnungen und was nicht alles.
Die wand gemalt wurde was angeblich jetzt alles sofort um uns hereinbrechen wird und dazu kann man nur sagen
tickets und tombola also das das das fand nicht statt und offensichtlich war da die einschätzung vieler rechts gelehrter nicht falsch also,
ist einfach so nicht gekommen und von daher ist es ein absoluter gewinn und
könnte könnte nochmal richtig in die annalen eingehen der gesetzgebung.
Ja also ich finde es vor allem auch spannend es wird halt eine also was wurde das ding diskutiert und.
Jetzt leider das scheint sich ja auch gezeigt zu haben das hatte jan philipp eiweiß in der ja auch schon so ein bisschen gesagt so jetzt muss man natürlich gucken.
Halten sich die leute auch dran und das scheint jetzt.
Halten sich auch die behörden die da angesprochen sind dran und das scheint ja so ein bisschen unterschiedlich zu laufen ja wir haben auf jeden fall die ein paar.
Artikel dazu auch nochmal in den shownotes und ich denke und hoffe mal dass der max schrems der jetzt.
Der sache ein bisschen druck macht weil mit vier business ist er ja auch also mit seiner die hat ja genau sich darauf konzentriert
und insofern ist natürlich auch ist er sicherlich derjenige der genau beurteilen kann ob da die verfahren verzögert werden oder nicht.
Wobei ich mir auch die arme irische datenschutzbeauftragte vorstellen kann wenn die da ein einschränkst nach dem anderen hingelegt kriegt weil die dinger haben ja in der regel hand und fuß und das ist natürlich das kann natürlich kopfschmerzen verursachen.
Letzter punkt nochmal korona ein bisschen ja da gab's eine,
ein forderung von daten journalistinnen und daten journalisten gegenüber dem.
Dass nämlich die daten so wie sie bisher verfügbar sind für
nicht nur für daten journalisten aber den fällt natürlich dann am massivsten auf dass diese daten einerseits nicht die qualität haben die sie vielleicht haben müssen und andererseits nicht den umfang
den sie bräuchten um hier wirklich die entscheidung die gefällt werden nachzuvollziehen oder überhaupt auch nur die betrachtung der situation so nachvollziehen zu können
und da haben sie dann mal einen offenen brief hingeschickt von dem man noch nicht genau weiß
ob er denn auch schon gelesen wurde als ich vermute mal das wird wahrscheinlich schon stattgefunden haben aber ob der dann auch ein entsprechender wirkung hat bisher gibt es da noch nicht so viel,
kurz kann man sagen es gibt zum beispiel so ein grundlegende probleme
die veröffentlichten daten halt nicht uneingeschränkt maschinen lesbar sind also auch vor allem nicht selbst beschreiben sind man muss da relativ viel rein investieren und
was bedeuten denn diese zahlen eigentlich dann fehlen daten
in konsistenzen all diese ganzen sachen die man so normalerweise auch kennt wenn man sich selber mal ein bisschen damit beschäftigt hat aber eben das eben auch viele angaben fehlen und da ist halt auch nicht ganz klar.
Inwiefern die dann überhaupt schon digital vorliegen also es wird ja einiges erhoben wenn jetzt
zum fall kommt dann wird der durch das contact tracing alles recherchiert man hinterfragt was ist eure situation welcher situation habt ihr euch angesteckt und unterscheidet zwischen index fällen und dann in zweiter linie
infizierten aber das sind halt alles daten die diese melde kette,
entweder gar nicht erst den weg dahin antreten oder deiner stelle nicht überleben,
man muss ja sehen gesundheitsämtern sind da der erste ort,
dann werden diese daten erfasst aber es ist halt die frage wenn ihr jetzt auf ein stück zettel geschrieben kommt die nur so eine excel-tabelle oder hat es in irgendeiner form auch eine methode so dass das eben dann auch beim land
landet wo dann eben die gesundheitsbehörde das dem meldet als zentrale sammelstelle,
und dann ist natürlich der nächste schritt werden auch alle daten die beim landen auch in der form wirklich veröffentlicht,
das sind so die die kernprobleme noch ergänzt um die problematik dass halt,
vor allem auch keine archive vorgehalten werden also die veröffentlichten daten werden jeden tag wieder so neu rausgehauen.
Enthalten aber dann änderungen die man dann den daten so als solchen gar nicht ansieht dass man kandidaten eigentlich nur dann verstehen wenn man sich im prinzip,
alle anderen veröffentlichungen auch noch mit anschaut nur dass die da halt nach einem tag gleich wieder verschwinden also muss quasi jeden tag sich die vollen datensätze ziehen,
um dann immer wieder zu vergleichen ja ok also hier steht jetzt das was standen da da vorher okay alles klar hat sich verändert also es ist wohl so und so ein zu sortieren und das ist halt eigentlich das ist einfach nur eine totale unart und von daher bin ich da auch ganz
bei den bei ihren forderungen ich habe das mit pavel auch bei u k w ausführlich diskutiert da wäre da auch,
genau an demselben thema dran sind ja auch dieselben daten nimmt für seine tolle risiko tabelle da kann man vielleicht noch mal kurz drauf hinweisen dass eigentlich die ausführlichst,
auswertung die man derzeit so nachschlagen kann insbesondere wenn man das geschehen in den landkreisen verstehen möchte war ja derzeit die situation ist landkreise.
Haben alle so diese magische schwelle von fünfzig neuinfektionen pro woche mittel und wenn man die überschreitet dann sollten ja schon wieder verschärften maßnahmen gelten oder lockerungen aufgehoben werden,
und das ist halt ja so aus dem
daten sehr schwer rauszuholen weil du hast dann sowieso eine komische map da kann man irgendwie klicken und so weiter du kannst alles nicht so richtig vergleichen oder findest du auf der karte dein landkreis gar nicht so richtig und,
bei paris risiko tabelle kann man das sehr schön sehen und dann berechnet da auch so ein paar andere lokale ehrenwerte,
woraus man halt ablesen kann wie es so ist und durch so eine einfache einfärbung sieht man halt sofort okay alles klar mein landkreis ist im grünen bereich oder im roten bereich oder wie wir es dann auch genannt haben im super roten und einen super grünen bereich was dann so die jeweiligen.
Punkte.
Infra grün infra grün.
Frage besonders langweiliges grün.
Ja da ist also wer bock auf mehr daten kram hat da kommt dann diese woche auch bei nochmal wasser wenn wir uns ja auch mit der thüringen situation und so weiter auseinandersetzen da kaufen wir das dann alles nochmal im detail durch.
Weißt du was die was die abkürzung von open corona data ist aussieht.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Aber er hat natürlich also es gehört sich es gehört sich so und ich weiß also als ich meine diplomarbeit abgegeben habe da habe ich auch ein reporter tory quasi dazu gegeben mit.
Mit meinem kompletten analyse und rohdaten halt ne das kann man durchaus machen bringt man sich ja keinen zacken außer krone würde dem jetzt auch nicht wehtun.
Ich denke das hat auch einfach was damit zu tun dass die selber die pavel immer so schön sagt das ist ja auch ihre erste pandemien.
Ja sie beschäftigen sich zwar die ganze zeit mit diesem kram aber mit diesen ausmaßen und mit diesem öffentlichen druck haben sie so ja auch noch nie zu tun gehabt und die
die masern ausbrüche um die zu dokumentieren hat es halt bis
bisher alles gereicht aber diese kombination aus das problem ist überall das problem ist international das interesse ist maximal der schaden der droht bei fehlentscheidungen ist auch maximal
viele daten und eben einem virus der sich auch noch den bisherigen erkenntnissen mustern dahingehend entzieht dass er eben so früh schon ansteckend ist bevor man irgendwas messen kann also da bricht
auf einmal sehr viel an annahmen weg die bisher immer gegolten haben.
Da ist es dann eben sich schnell sichtbar dass wir einfach einen extremen rückstau haben in der digitalisierung.
Der ja schon mal geplant war und der irgendwie ende dieses jahres dann auch theoretisch mal fertig sein sollte in diesem ganzen meldeweg.
Und das fällt einem natürlich jetzt ein bisschen auf die füße,
pandemien hätte auch zwei jahre später kommen können hätten wir vielleicht schon besser da gestanden aber ich lese jetzt in der berichterstattung ehrlich gesagt das wort fax noch zu oft.
Also es ist.
Das hat da einfach nicht mehr zu sein in den zwanziger jahren des letzten jahrhunderts und das ist einfach das wort fax will ich jetzt einfach nur noch in historischen dokumentationen sehen ja.
Güter weirauch und so.
Gestern abend lief das hatte ich mir noch gestern abend lief eine
dokumentation wohl ich glaube in der ard oder so über die fehlgeschlagene digitalisierung versuche der bundesrepublik die wollte ich mir noch anschauen die gibt's bestimmt in der in der mediathek per nötige zustimmen der fern.
Das ist doch schön.
Bücher verleiht bücher verleiht fax.
Ist ein großes ding ey.
Wichtige arbeitgeber das werden wir noch längere zeit retten müssen diese diese industrie okay gut.
Ich würde gerne noch kurz danken und zwar marcel matthias und robert und.
Mal wieder einer unbekannten person und wenn ihr diese unbekannte person euch angesprochen fühlt freue ich mich über einen kurzen hinweis über die.
Bekannten kanäle zum beispiel kontaktformular auf meiner webseite.
Genau ich grüße auch alle anderen unbekannten personen die so fleißig dazu beitragen dass der spendenerlös über eins liegt und,
ansonsten war's das von uns für diese woche wir entlassen euch wieder in die in die freiheit.
Was haben wir denn diesem land auch für eine freiheit.
Ihr könnt jede woche hören ich meine wenn euch das nicht reicht.
Okay auf wiederhören.
Tschüss.